[Musique]
dans l'actualité cette semaine un baby
si dating a pris place à montigny le
bretonneux au total une quarantaine de
familles et 56 baby sitter entre 16 et
25 ans se sont rencontrés à l'université
versailles saint quentin a organisé son
3e symposium sport santé à l'ufr simone
veil en compagnie de sportifs de
chercheurs et de professionnels de santé
l'occasion de revenir sur l'institut
santé passeport connecter un
établissement dédié au sport et au
handicap prévu pour 2024 aux mureaux une
vingtaine d'associations se sont réunis
devant la médiathèque de montier le
bretonneux à l'occasion de la sixième
édition de la journée des possibles
l'objectif était de sensibiliser aux
enjeux environnementaux
vingaard pourrait fermer sur la ligne
gicler relie paris saint lazare à
l'ouest parisien c'est ce qu'a annoncé
la cgt cheminots mentez vexin en cause
un nouveau contrat ile-de-france
mobilité voulu par la région mardi avait
lieu le forum des associations à
l'université versailles saint quentin le
plaisir de constater un retour à la vie
étudiante et à la vie normale tous les
étudiants peuvent maintenant revenir en
cours en présentiel
[Musique]